I
a lot of these people are on kind of
similar work schedules we're working a
mile a minute very easy just because I
don't have a lot of time it makes it
very easy to meter to arrange and meet
people you know with a lot of a lot of
people the inner circle is an
invitation-only dating website for
inspiring attractive professionals our
members connect with friends and revel
their website is by invitation only so
you need to be invited by a friend to
become a member and then we screen every
profile to ensure we maintain the right
quality standards London only starts at
ten thousand to sterling and runs
anything up to 50,000 US dollars
depending on which area of the word you
wish to be a member in this is for the
one percent this is for the cash-rich
time for client that needs to be that
needs a top class service and somebody
that can look after and have their best
interests at heart
the quality of people would have to be
stellar I would want to date a Nobel
Prize winner for that money I think